hey youtubers it's Charlie so today is
gonna be all killer frost everybody dust
off your winter is coming puns because
we are probably gonna see her on the
flash season two there are actually four
different versions of her character in
the comics but the important one is
Caitlin snow the most recent version
because she's being played by the very
wonderful danielle panabaker on the
flash a new round of the DC giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video special giveaway whenever
we get a comic-con so just careful for
spoilers for the flash season 1 if you
haven't seen the finale yet because I'll
be talking about Caitlin snow killer
frost we got a teaser for in that finale
and there there were a lot of questions
as to what that meant what Barry was
seeing he was traveling along his own
timeline so that was presumably
something from the future the way the
reverse-flash explained it Barry was
seeing events across all points of his
timeline like the current timeline so
the way I see it our current version of
Caitlin is going to become killer frost
in the future unless team flash tries to
do something crazy to change the future
that would create a new timeline but
remember the reverse flash said that
when you try and do that when you try to
change the future to avoid some some big
catastrophic event time will find a way
to replace that with something just as
bad you also to consider that the riders
on the flash probably wouldn't tease us
with something like danielle Panabaker
and killer frost if they never intended
to deliver it so unless they say
otherwise at Comic Con next week plan on
killer frost at some point in season 2
the real question is why white a super
nice karaoke best friend Caitlin turned
into killer frost we know she's a
metahuman but the way she looks now and
the way she looked in that vision are
dramatically different like she had
super blonde hair her version of the
character is the fourth killer frost
she's like the new 52 killer frost
although technically there were two
killer Frost's appear during the new 52
DC just rebooted their entire line so we
don't know what's gonna happen with
killer frost going forward but
presumably they let Caitlin snow keep on
being killer frost because DC and Marvel
have both started to make the comics
look a little bit more like the movies
and the TV shows that they do Felicity
Smoak is a really good example of that
in the the Green Arrow comics
he actually started out a long time ago
during the firestorm comics as the
stepmom of Ronnie Raymond cut to write
now in the comics you know because of
the popularity of the character on arrow
they started to make her look more like
the TV show version of the character so
yay for Emily MetroCards maybe they'll
do the same thing with danielle
panabaker we'll see you can see like
DC's thought process where it's like
millions of people see a certain version
of a character on TV and they're
thinking well hate you know maybe they
want to read more stories with this
character so let's make comic books that
reflect that it's true for both Marvel
and DC like the films and the TV shows
drive up comic book sales big time the
original version of the character kind
of has a funny story especially when you
think about it in the context of the TV
show characters the very first version
of the character was named crystal Frost
she started out in firestorm number
three she was one of Martin Stein
students she fell in love with him but
because he wasn't the pervy kind of
college professor he turned her down she
got super pissed locked herself in a
chamber and you wind up with a pretty
standard science experiment gone wrong
origin story she came out of this
special chamber with ice based powers
her motivation as a villain became
attacking men like she hated men she
literally had a frozen heart so you get
the metaphor Martin Stein turned her art
to ice and then it literally turned to
ice the reason she started attacking
firestorm was because Martin Stein was
one half of firestorm she ended up dying
whenever she absorbed too much of his
heat energy though but she was
resurrected as a black lantern during
blackest night you really got to watch
out how you treat those ex-girlfriend
because they might come back as super
zombies so the next killer frost was
Louise Lincoln she debuted in firestorm
vol 2 number 21 but she didn't become
killer frost until about 13 issues later
she was actually like a best friend and
colleague of Krystal frost she idolized
her so much that she tried to recreate
the accident that gave her the killer
frost powers it worked and she started
trying to get revenge on firestorm for
crystals death mostly you will probably
know this version of the character as
the Suicide Squad version you can also
color the sexy version of the character
they gave her like giant boobs they just
they softened all her features they made
her more attractive this version of the
character is the one that they used
during the assault on arkham anime
movie last year if you haven't seen that
you should check it out I mean it's a
good movie all by itself she even became
part of this frozen villain team-up you
know DC has a lot of like ice based
villains so Gorilla Grodd in the in this
instance where he was attacking a bunch
of superheroes mine controls mr. freeze
icicle Captain Cold
and killer frost to team up against
superheroes she even fought Oliver Queen
in Green Arrow volume 3 number 55 that
was about 10 years ago but it was before
the new 52 reboot he defeated her by
shooting her with a Greek fire arrow
which we have not seen on the TV show
yet that'd be pretty badass
for those of you that don't know what
Greek fire is it's a lot like wildfire
on Game of Thrones you you can't put it
out with water either have to smother it
or cut its oxygen supply off after the
new 52 reboot Lauren frontier became the
new killer frost for a brief period she
debuted whenever the new firestorm
kicked off fire storm version form that
was when they changed the way fire
storms powers worked and Jason Rusch and
Ronnie Raymond both are able to become
firestorm on their own so she attacks
them but they fuse to make a single
firestorm in the reaction that that
causes takes her down in a little while
after that in 2013 a couple years later
but still during the new 52 they
introduced the Caitlin snow killer frost
her origin story is kind of a twist on
the first two versions of the characters
origin stories that that chemical
reaction like that the science
experiment accident the twist is is that
the accident was caused by hive agents
like she's in a facility investigating
this device hive agents have infiltrated
she gets trapped goes through the
reaction and comes out with killer frost
powers the difference this time is is
that she's more of like a heat vampire
that that's her motivation whenever she
absorbs heat it makes her look more
human-like it slowly returns her to a
more normal state so she's always
constantly seeking heat sources to
absorb the reason she goes after
firestorm is because he's like an
unlimited source of heat so she's not
she's not in love with him like Caitlin
on the TV show is you can see how the TV
show version of the character is kind of
a blend of all these different killer
frost characters we can only guess as to
why she might turn against team flash
and why her appearance would change why
she get that light colored hair but just
expect the writers to pull
from her comic book history to
incorporate it into the TV show it's the
same way that Barry Allen on the TV show
is kind of a combination of Wally West
in the comics and Barry Allen in the
comics so like I said her powers are
pretty similar to a lot of the other eye
space villains like she just has like
standard eye space attacks but the newer
versions of the character can absorb
heat she's also been able to mind
control people by kissing them if you're
wondering what she might look like on
the TV show then just think of what
Captain Cold would look like if he
didn't need the gun so here my big
question for you guys on the TV show
what do you think is going to happen to
turn Caitlin snow into full-blown killer
frost we just learned in the finale that
she and Cisco are both metahumans so she
probably doesn't know that she has
powers yet because Cisco didn't know he
had powers what they might do is choose
to honor the original version of the
character and make her turn cold
metaphorically because of something with
Ronnie Raymond they just got married
she's super in love with him remember
how she got when she thought he was
still dead so if he were sidelined or
something happened to him something
terrible that might push her over the
edge
she knows that Barry can go back in time
so if she were to like ask Barry hey can
you go back in time change the past so
that this does not happen to Ronnie and
he refuses that that might be something
to create a huge rift between them
because even if she does get powers that
doesn't explain why she would turn
against team flash and no matter what
she ends up doing don't think of her as
an outright villain like even Captain
Cold isn't an outright villain he's more
of an antagonist who's going to be an
antihero during legends of tomorrow not
quite good but not quite bad for those
asking about Comic Con though we
actually have a little bit of
information about what's going on with
all the DC TV shows they're doing the
big DC super panel like they did last
year but they'll mostly be there to show
off new stuff for legends of tomorrow
and Supergirl but but they will have
like arrow and flash stuff they haven't
started shooting the new seasons yet so
it's not like they have big trailers to
show off but Stephen Amell did promise
that they would be bringing something
special the only way I'd be allowed to
post footage would be if DC says it's
okay but usually they're really good
about posting that stuff online so I'm
not too worried about that so in
addition to posting the panel stuff I
should be able to post like the new to
the new footage - I haven't completely
worked out my schedule yet but later
this
I'm gonna start doing specific comic-con
previews that'll say you know what the
schedules gonna be when I'm gonna post
videos what's gonna be happening so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
it's gonna be crazy comic-con will be a
little bit more laid-back this year but
they'll still be at least like 10 or 14
videos that I'll be posting I'll explain
that stuff a little bit better in the
comic-con previews so look out for that
starting like Thursday or Friday I will
leave you with this one teaser for the
flash season 2 Grant Gustin said that we
would learn who the villain is right
away and it would be a crossover villain
with legends of tomorrow so Vandal
Savage might also be the big bad on
flash season 2
everybody just explode about that in the
comments just in case you guys didn't
see it I posted a video last week
explaining what's going on with the
flash season 2 premiere and arrow season
4 so you can click here to learn all
about that and you can click here to
learn all about the multiverse on the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow